today on the matt walsh show i am being
canceled for criticizing the lgbt
indoctrination of children
i'll address that today also five
headlines including marjorie taylor
green is being called a bigot and a
transphobe for defending biological
science
west virginia moves to ban critical race
theory and the cruise industry starts to
institute vaccine requirements for
passengers is that a sign of things to
come
in our daily cancellation we'll talk
about canada's recent anti-bullying
campaign which promises to be about as
effective as
every other anti-bullying campaign which
is not at all all of that and more today
on the matt wall show
[Music]
[Applause]
last night after our backstage episode
wrapped which by the way you should go
to dailywire.com or youtube after you're
done with this show to watch it
uh but only after you're done with this
show i logged onto twitter to discover
that i was trending
nationwide one thing i've learned over
the years is that when i trend it's
never because everyone is happy about
something i said i've never trended
because everyone is saying wow i agree
with
this point that matt walsh made i'm not
sure if anyone trends for that reason
but i certainly don't
for me it's always because people are
very mad very upset very outraged about
some opinion or
some other opinion that i expressed that
was certainly the case here
in this situation people uh on the
internet were were quite
apoplectic about a tweet that i sent out
in reaction to a new gallup poll which
showed that the number of kids and young
adults who identify as lgbt
has risen in an extraordinary and sudden
way
over the last few years this is what i
wrote
i said the number of kids who identify
as lgbt especially trans and bisexual
has absolutely skyrocketed
if you think this is a natural or
organic development you're deluded the
media hollywood and the school system
actively recruit children into the lgbt
ranks
i followed that up with this i said the
number of supposedly trans children and
young adults is 10 times higher than the
number among older generations
do you think that's because a lot more
people are born in the wrong body these
days whatever the hell that means
no this is social engineering in our
culture the lgbt lobby
poses the greatest threat to our
children especially the tea party
so there it is the opinion that i have
been
that's the opinion that i've been
reliably informed by thousands of people
is detestable
outrageous hateful bigoted and so on and
much of the reaction
was exceedingly unhinged but none more
so than the response from parker malloy
over at media matters
who sent out a frantic string of tweets
implying
that i'm a pedophile for these opinions
on what basis were these accusations
made well
no basis of course it's just that parker
malloy disagrees with me
thus feels entitled to make up literally
any lie
at all in retribution those tweets have
all now been
deleted by the way this is what we're
dealing with
from the opposition people scummy enough
to defame and slander their ideological
opponents
but too cowardly to stand by the
defamation
most of the rest of the tweets and
messages i've received have been more
along the lines of you know calling me a
piece of garbage an idiot
a worthless sack of such and such i
should kill myself etc and so forth
so first of all after receiving all of
this feedback and seeing that my words
were so deeply hurtful to so many people
i want to say with all sincerity
that i am not sorry at all not even a
little bit
i couldn't be less sorry for what i said
i'm 100 right everything i said was
absolutely and totally correct and i'm
so happy that i said it
i am not and could never be sorry for
being right i will
i will however happily accept the
apologies of any of my critics
should they decide to offer them i'm all
ears for that i am a gracious and
forgiving man in that way
but as for being sorry myself not a
chance not ever
not ever i am though happy to explain
why i'm right about what i said this is
an important issue
by far one of the most important issues
that our culture faces in the present
moment
it's worth talking about in greater
detail so first let's go back and look
at the numbers okay
according to gallup the overall number
of americans who identify as lgbt is up
to 5.6 percent that's a one percent
increase from the last tally in 2017
that's a significant jump in just three
or four years
but the truly seismic shifts can be seen
among the youngest generations
among gen z and gallup defines that as
those born between 1997 and 2002
so this doesn't even take into account
the very youngest generations
where we can assume the figures are even
more dramatic
but among gen z a full 16 15.9 to be
exact
identify as lgbt another
five percent have apparently no opinion
about their own sexual orientation
breaking down the numbers further 2.1
percent of gen z say they're gay 1.4
percent say lesbian both of these
figures represent at least a doubling
over gen x and older generations
and then another another 11.5 percent
say they're bisexual
the number of trans people in gen z is
almost 2
1.8 right now now that might seem like a
small portion but keep in mind
that 1.8 is nearly 10 times higher as i
said in the tweet
nearly 10 times higher than the portion
among
gen x and older generations and keep in
mind again
also that this does not take into
account those who are born
after 2002 and it's the after 2002
generation those who were born while i
was in high school
who've really been hit the hardest by
lgbt indoctrination
yes lgbt indoctrination that is what's
happening here
and i cannot take seriously anyone who
would deny it
the drag queen story hours the trans
books for kids
the gender theory propaganda shoved into
kids minds of the youngest ages
the constant promotion of lgbt
lifestyles and identities by school
hollywood the media and so on
all of this has two clear and purposeful
effects
number one it makes it seem trendy and
cool to be lgbt we've gone way beyond
mere acceptance or toleration
we have long since gone way beyond those
things
it is now for many young people seen as
more interesting more fashionable to be
able to tack a few letters from the
sacred initialism onto your name
you know years of associating being
cisgender and white with being
privileged
and being privileged with being an
oppressor and a bully has an impact it
turns out
it's supposed to have an impact it is
designed to have the very impact
that it's having but if you point out
that the strategies are working
you'll be called a bigot for noticing
that there's a strategy at all
so that's the first thing the second is
that kids are being taught
to view sex gender and sexual
orientation a certain way
they're being indoctrinated into a view
of sex and orientation
that when adopted by large numbers of
people will automatically and by design
increase the lgbt ranks for example
kids are being taught now that if you're
a boy with feminine tendencies
then you might actually be a girl if
you're a girl with masculine tendencies
you might actually be a boy kids are
taught that this is a a possibility and
encouraged to explore
that possibility back when kids were not
being taught this kind of
anti-scientific nonsense
a girl with masculine tendencies was
just a girl with masculine tendencies a
tomboy we might have called her
some girls were that way and that was
fine
some boys were more feminine and that
was fine too now
we're ushering those types of girls and
boys under the trans umbrella what we're
effectively saying is
you can't be that kind of girl or boy
anymore those don't exist anymore
because if you're a feminine boy then
you're a girl if you're a masculine girl
then you're a boy
why do you think there are now more
young people who call themselves trans
than call themselves lesbian
and there are almost as many and soon
will be more young people calling
themselves trans than gay
why is that because we've given young
people this new
framework for understanding themselves
the problem is that the framework is
totally false incoherent and based in
pseudoscience
so yes in effect
these children are being recruited to be
trans
they're being turned trans yes
that is what is happening kids are being
turned trans they are being made into
something
they are not this is deliberate it is
diabolical
it is damaging and destroying many
children
and i will not ever stop calling it what
it is no matter how loud the mob
screams or what labels they throw at me
none of that matters to me
what matters is the truth and this is it
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
speaking of which we'll start here
number one representative marjorie
taylor greene
tried to um tried to block the radical
so-called
equality act which is a horrifically bad
law that we'll discuss
at greater length tomorrow but suffice
to say for now that uh if you haven't
read much about this law um which dems
are going to vote on this week and
they'll pass
you know this this is the consequence of
the democrats
having uh both houses of congress and
and um both chambers of congress and the
presidency you know they can pass laws
like this and the equality act
will have the effect of basically
erasing
women legally speaking
and marjorie taylor green is one of uh
of
the republicans who has tried to block
this has opposed it
now the democrats don't like this so
democratic
congresswoman marie newman responded to
this
um to this move by by green by placing a
trans flag outside
of marjory taylor green's office and she
took a video which you can see here she
was very proud
and she took a video of herself
placing the trans flag outside of the
office
now my question is
um you see there she's putting it in a
flag holder
right outside of mtg's office
what flag was in that holder before
that's what i want to know
that's my first question it's possible
they installed a new flag holder but i i
actually doubt they did my guess is that
flag holder was already there
so what flag was occupying that holder
before they put the trans flag there
what flag was taken down
so that they could put a trans flag in
i'd really like to know the answer to
that question
i mean i have some guesses did they take
down
did did this woman take down an american
flag to put a trans flag in his place i
don't know
interesting question though now um so
that's what that that's that was her
response that was the
the high school level response where now
we
and and by the way even if they didn't
take that i mean maybe it was a it was
an empty
flag holder or something even if they
didn't take down
um the american flag
it is still a disgrace uh and in my
opinion a desecration of the american
flag
that you would put the trans flag there
in this hallway with a bunch of american
flags
flags that have real meaning and mean
something you put a trans flag there
you know sending the symbolic message
that this flag is is is equal to as
meaningful as an american flag it's not
the trans flag doesn't mean anything
what does it mean to have a flag
for your orientation or your so-called
gender identity what
what what do you need the flag for
what what is that exactly the whole idea
of your
your identity or your orientation having
its own flag
is absurd
but regardless there was um
representative newman doing that
well marjorie taylor green responds with
her own video
uh and in in her video she she places a
sign
that says there are two genders male and
female
trust the science outside of newman's
door
and she also takes a video for of her
putting herself up putting that that
sign up there
which i think is great and now of course
so we have the okay here's the video
here
yeah the sign says there are two genders
male and female
does that say follow the signs or trust
the signs trust the science i think
and so she puts that she puts that sign
up there now you could call this whole
thing
it's it's exceedingly childish on both
ends you could say but
i i i'm i'm i don't think that's the
case i think it's childish on the part
of
newman that she started this whole thing
but this is a response in kind
and by the way it seems like
representative newman
and all the other democrats this is a
reminder that they need
like there should be more of those signs
saying there are there are two
um genders actually there are two sexes
you know because gender is
is we won't get into this i don't i
don't want to split hairs but um
gender is a made-up concept as it
pertains to human beings
words gender is a grammatical concept
words have gender
human beings have sex have have a sex
you're a male or a female
we don't need both of those and as we've
talked about
before uh this idea that human beings
have a gender
and a sex was invented out of whole
cloth
by uh a few crackpots in the mid 20th
century
principle among them would be john money
who as you know from listening to this
show
john money invented left-wing gender
theory back in the 1950s and 60s
um he was he was a quack he was a
pedophile apologist
an actual pedophile apologist as in he
defended some forms of pedophilia
and um and uh he he tested his gender
theories on two young boys who later
went on to kill themselves
so uh this was a theory that he invented
out of whole cloth
and he tried one experiment to test its
legitimacy and it failed so miserably
that it ended with the
deaths of two people so anyway that's
why we should say sex not gender but
regardless
she puts that that sign up that's a sign
that
democrats need to see that's a reminder
that they need
but what's happened of course is that
all of the backlash is to
marjorie taylor green and not newman
calling her a transphobe and a bigot and
all these things
simply for for affirming
the reality of biological sex
and this isn't going to shock you
probably isn't going to shock you at
least it shouldn't
a lot of republicans or at least a few
that i've seen and probably more to come
have come out against margie telegram
for doing this
some republicans in congress have
accused her of
of bigotry for putting that sign up
if you want to know why the republican
party is utterly irrelevant
and just lost everything in the last
election that's why not because of mars
retail agreement but because of the
republicans that would
condemn her for simply asserting
the truth of biological science okay
number two this is from the daily wire
it says west virginia is the latest
state seeking to ban
so-called critical race theory from the
state's workplaces schools and
government agencies
house bill 2595 would prohibit
discriminatory divisive acts in the
workplace
end the teaching of divisive acts in
west virginia schools and ban the state
funding to agencies who promote divisive
acts
the legislation outlines divisive
concepts are defined to include the
concept that one race or sex is
inherently superior to another race or
sex
that the united states is fundamentally
racist or sexist
that an individual by virtue of his or
her sex race or sex is inherently racist
sexist or oppressive whether consciously
or unconsciously
that an individual should be
discriminated against or receive adverse
treatments solely or partly because of
his or her race or sex
that members of one race or sex cannot
and should not attempt to treat others
without respect to uh to race or sex
that an individual's moral character is
necessarily determined
by his or her race or sex so these are
all
con this is how they are defining
divisive concepts that they're looking
to outlaw
in the workplace um and then uh and
and and they they go into greater to
more detailed definitions as well
i think this is great this this is what
state houses need to do
need to pass laws like this there need
to be laws passed this is what
conservatives should be pushing for
not merely complaining about it but
doing
something and one thing that we can do
especially if you control a state house
pass a law against it
that needs to happen also lawsuits
if you're an employee at coca-cola or
one of these
countless other companies that are
singling you out
based on your race and
insulting you harassing you based on
your race
you need to file a lawsuit
to sit there obediently and take it if
if that's what you're going to do then
it's never going to end
file lawsuit make them defend it in
court
and look the courts are
largely run by the left as well so maybe
the lawsuit isn't successful but we at
least
have to force them to defend it force
them to go into court in front of a
judge and explain how this does not
count as
racial harassment
now the thing about this law speaking of
racial harassment
um race-based harassment in the
workplace is already illegal
so this law shouldn't be necessary
what this law is doing is making
something illegal that's already illegal
but the law is necessary because because
the current law the current federal law
and policies are not being equally
enforced
and so now west virginia is passing
another law that's more specific
make very clear that this applies to all
races
it's not just that you're not allowed to
racially harass certain races but you
can with others
we shouldn't need a law like this but we
do
and anyone who says that this is an
infringement on um
on you know the the rights of business
owners or anything
anyone who says that is is is
silly um what this is again doing is
outlawing race-based harassment in the
workplace
now if you want to take the uber
libertarian position and say that
race-based harassment in the workplace
should be allowed for anybody
then go ahead and defend that position
that's not the position i would take but
go ahead and defend it
but make sure you defend it consistently
number three nbc is getting some
backlash
over a scene from a show called nurses
which i've never heard of this show
before but apparently
it fills the need for another medical
drama on network tv because we've only
seen about 53
000 of those so we needed another one
and uh and here's this one
this scene portrays a hasidic jew
refusing a bone graft
from a non-jew you know because he's
he's
he's
religious and therefore a bigot
according to uh the people who come up
with these shows let's let's watch this
scene
the raft where does it come from it's
called an aloe bone graft it's harvested
from a deceased donor
but you want to put a dead leg inside of
me they're going leg
from anyone an arab a woman or god
forbidden arab woman
[Music]
look you can't be lugging this metal
cage around no
i don't consent ezreal without this next
step you will never walk properly again
which means forget about basketball
which is obviously what he wants
[Music]
it's god who heals what he creates
[Music]
a dead [ __ ] leg wouldn't want one of
those
uh there's there's a lot of backlash to
nbc for this
as i said um and there should be because
this is
obviously um
making a caricature of religious jews
and it's as far as i'm aware i'm i'm
no expert on the specifics of jewish law
but as far as i'm aware
this is completely made up there is no
jewish law that would
prohibit you know someone from getting a
bone graft
um from a non-jew so they've they've
made up this
this rule of judaism just so that they
could slander religious people
um and that's outrageous we should also
note though that
this is what network tv does to
christians every single day this is this
is
this is uh not just anti-jewish bigotry
or anti-christian it's anti-religious
that's what we're getting i mean
they they love to make the religious
people the villains if they need a
stand-in if they need just a scene with
some sort of
ignorant person well make them religious
and as christians we've been dealing
with this for years where they they
they'll make up rules of christianity
that don't exist
or a whole new form of christianity
doesn't exist uh
just so that they can have a character
who adopts that made-up form
and then they can use that to slander
christians in general so we've seen this
over and over again it is an
anti-religious thing with one exception
so it's anti-religious um the only
exception would be of course
islam so you're never going to see a
scene like that on network tv especially
on a
network like nbc where that person is a
muslim
objecting to you know a bone graft from
an infidel infidel
so they make the one exception but all
other religions
they hate except for the religion
obviously of
of uh of leftism which is itself its own
religion
number four i'm sorry i have to do this
but but i think i do um
the tick tock singers are at it again
and i need to play these
for you a lot of people complain when i
play this stuff
they say you know why are you subjecting
us to this well it's for your own good
for your own good now sit down shut up
and listen to this
if i had to hear it then so do you we've
got two now we've got two
tick tock singers we'll play the first
one this is a teacher
in her classroom so at least she's she's
she's at school she's back in class i
don't know where this teacher is
but she's in the classroom good for her
except the only problem is that she's in
the classroom so that she can record
tick-tock singing videos and here it is
let's listen if you don't believe that
there's white privilege please don't
teach
if you don't believe that black lives
matter please don't teach
if you don't believe in systemic racism
and how it negatively impacts our
students of color
and don't want to help dismantle those
systems please don't
teach
oh dear lord the thing that always gets
me with these videos is the expression
you can see the expression on her face
the expression they made that on their
face at the end of it they're so proud
of themselves
and they feel like they've really
accomplished something i don't know what
they think they've accomplished
what are what are you going for here
what result are you hoping for
because all you're going to get is
mockery
and scorn from almost everybody
i assume you didn't want that what did
you think was going to happen did you
think that the internet
you would put this out there into
cyberspace and the response from the
internet would be
wow wow gee that's a great song miss can
you sing another
that one was pretty bad this one's even
worse let's listen
if you're white yes you are racist even
if you think you're woke
we all benefit from oppression
pretending you're not racist
only makes racism grow
kind of like the first song better i
have to say the first song was a little
bit
catchier she needs some work on that one
wasn't a big fan there i it's probably
not worth dissecting
you know the the argument such as it was
which she presented there but um she
seems to be saying that
she says if you're white you're racist
and the reason why
you're racist as a white person because
you you benefit from oppression
which now i reject that premise i don't
think that every white person
automatically benefits from
oppression and most of what she would
consider oppression i don't think is
oppression at all
but uh but even if that were true how
does that make you racist
i mean for the sake of argument if you
if i were to agree that white people
benefit from oppression why does that
make them racist automatically well
she can't explain she doesn't need to
explain it that's why she's singing
um all right we'll move on finally the
the daily wire has some unfortunate news
if you're planning to take a cruise
anytime soon
says crystal cruises has announced a
plan to require all passengers to be
fully vaccinated against covenanting at
least 14 days
before they take a voyage on their ships
and passengers will have to provide
proof of the vaccination
the company said in a statement the
company has voluntarily passed
or paused operations through may 2021
for its river fleet into june for its
ocean tips
ships and through august 1st for crystal
espirit
allowing most travelers sufficient time
to get fully vaccinated before crystal's
resumption of sailing
the company said it hopes by the time it
resumes operations vaccines will be
widely available to americans
and then there are let's see
last november top travel industry
association said it was in the final
stages developing a digital passport for
international travelers
so they can prove that they've been
vaccinated for kova 19
and it looks like a number of other
cruise companies have also adopted this
crystal is the fourth company to
announce it will require vaccines for
its passengers
american queens steamboat company and
victory cruise lines
both did so earlier this month so it
seems
so far this is something we're mainly
seeing from the cruise industry
requiring vaccinations will it become a
trend that catches on
uh i mean the major airlines will i
think a few airlines are
right now at least regional airlines
will the major delta you know we start
seeing that i don't know um
if if this has the effect of
discouraging people from going on a
cruise
then probably all for for the best
honestly i don't know why you'd want to
go on a cruise anyway
especially now after we we saw what
happened i mean
we think back to last spring there were
these horror stories covet breaks out on
the ship and everyone's quarantined on
the ship
in their little cabins for weeks but
even aside from that i can tell you as
someone who's been
i went on one cruise one time and um
[Music]
i can tell you it's it's not the way to
travel it just doesn't
the the one advantage of the cruise
there's there's only one good thing
about a cruise
and that is the food you just eat
all you do on the cruise is constantly
eat
there's always some sort of buffet
available
and you're constantly eating and
drinking too
and the way they get you on the cruise
is that they give you at least the
cruise that i went on i don't know if
i assume this is probably the universal
standard but they give you a little card
so they don't charge for the drinks the
food is actually free
the drinks seem like they're free they
don't charge you for it at the time but
they give you this nice little nifty
card
and it's not it's not like a credit card
it's just it's a nice little card
and every time you get a drink they you
just hang on the card they quickly swipe
it no big deal
and you're drinking you're having a good
time and then on the last day of the
cruise they stick that bill under the
door for all the drinks you had
and then you look at that and say did i
really drink 800 worth of booze in three
days
apparently i did so stay away from
cruises all right let's go to uh reading
the comments now
this is from username is ted kazin
kozinski i'm i'm
thinking not the actual guy but who
knows he says
teach statistical literacy not critical
race theory
yeah i i agree we talked yesterday about
how americans
according to a survey by skeptic
magazine americans
vastly uh overestimate
the number of unarmed black men that are
killed by police every year
i mean there's a preponderance of
americans that think that like a
thousand or ten thousand
unarmed black men are killed by police
every year
and a lot of that goes to like we talked
about media propaganda
this is this is the the disinformation
campaign from the media bearing its
fruits
but yeah it does it does also speak to
um a more general problem that i've
noticed among americans
which is having no concept of how
statistics work
no way to measure these things in in
your head
because even if you have bought into
media disinformation
i mean 10 000 a year
this is something that they should be
teaching in schools is statistics
how do they work giving people a good
sense of them but um
no they're not they're not focused on
that sarah wooten says personally matt
in addition to the longer shows i would
also like for you to star in a movie as
gina
as gina's rollerblading crime fighting
sidekick
otherwise you're cancelled well sarah
you know i don't like when people make
demands
normally i would ban you from the show
for that but i love the suggestion
and i would do that in a heartbeat
um ali boo says i would rather have one
giraffe than 10 000 people
well if that's the case then you're a
sociopath see i always assume
that the people who pretend to value
animals over people
are doing just that pretending
but if you actually would value a
giraffe over
a person maybe i should start taking
people more seriously when they make
this claim
because if that's really the case then
you're simply a sociopath
so i'm going to hope that it's not um
luca says matt what do you use as bait
for phishing
i you know i'm more of a finesse fisher
so i fishermen so i use the
rubber worms and that kind of thing
that's i i tend to go more with that i
like those over the moving baits
the youth of the nation says you know
you're young when matt says walkman
and cassette and you think he's speaking
russian great show matt
yeah well that's that's the cut off so
you you you you missed the days
of uh not just walkman and cassette
but that was back in the day if you
wanted to make a mixtape you don't know
anything about this because you're a
youngster
but back in my day you would have the
recording cassette
empty cassette you know you put it in
your boom box
and if you wanted to make a mixtape you
would sit by the radio
and wait for them to play that your
favorite song and hit hit play and
record
and you'd make your it could take it
could take all day it takes 16 hours to
get like the seven songs you want on
your mixtape
that took effort
your kids don't know anything about that
these days um
asian eggs says should probably skip the
next episode i think it's going to be
real bad
episode 666. yeah a lot of comments
about the fact that this show
is episode 666 that's true i'm not
worried about that
i just want to say i'm not superstitious
just a number
so relax besides i sprinkled the studio
with holy water before the show so
i think we're good it's more important
now than it's ever been to support
companies
that have morals to support companies
that support
us and the culture companies are they're
working for us and with us
as conservatives and pro-lifers and one
company that fits that description to a
t
is charity mobile they're the pro-life
phone company and they earn that
uh that that label uh by
for one thing five percent of your
monthly plan price goes to
the pro-life pro family charity of your
choice and that's you know that's that's
the charity that comes with it so that
you're
you're getting a great service and you
know that you're doing good work at the
same time
you're helping the pro-life cause you're
also supporting a company that helps a
pro-life cause
and on top of that there are a lot of
great perks as well you get new
activations eligible accounts
get a free cell phone with free
activation and free shipping
there's no contract there's no
termination fees and what i
always tell people when they ask about
charity mobile is there's no risk with a
30 day guarantee so you might as well
give it a shot try it out and i think
you're gonna you're gonna love charity
mobile they also have live customer
service based right here in the usa
on top of that free usage alerts free
apps to
monitor your usage pay your bill and
much more so the convenience that comes
with it
as well but it all comes down to the
fact that you're helping to build a
culture of life
in america while supporting a pro-life
phone company and you get that
nationwide service on america's largest
and most reliable 4g
lte network i use charity mobile that's
that's service i go with and i could be
happy with it no complaints at all
call us at 1-877-474-3662 or chat with
them
online at charitymobile.com
uh also you know there are so many
narratives around hot topic hot topic
issues and it's hard to keep track of
all the newest controversies that the
left
decides to be offended by it's always a
new thing every day so get ready for the
daily wires newest show soon to be
released that's debunked
where ben shapiro exposes leftist
fallacies in 15 minutes or less
climate change universal healthcare
covet policies all these
he's using facts and logic going up
against the media narrative
this show will be available exclusively
to daily wire members so if you aren't
already a member go to dailywire.com
subscribe and use code debunked to get
25
off you'll want to miss ben so use code
debunked to get 25
off now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
today we're going to cancel canada again
this makes canada now the most canceled
country a well-deserved distinction
this time they're in for a cancellation
because of something called pink shirt
day
which was evidently observed yesterday
here is the premiere of ontario doug
ford explaining it
today is pink shirt day it's a day when
people come together
by wearing pink to school or work to
show they're against bullying
bullying hurts if you're being bullied
know that you aren't alone reach out and
talk to someone you trust
everyone should feel safe supported and
accepted
wherever they go we all deserve to be
treated
with dignity and respect on pink shirt
day
wear pink and stand up against bullying
and promote the importance of being kind
reach out reach out
it's like kind of like oat reach an oat
reach out say your story yes we're going
to end bullying by wearing
a pink shirt and if that doesn't work we
can try a blue shirt maybe a red shirt
red may be the ticket red means stop so
bullies will see the red shirt and
they'll think
i should stop bullying at which point
they'll open up the locker and let the
nerd run free again who knows you know
it could work that way
probably not but it could you know we
haven't heard as much about bullying
this past year with kids locked in their
homes staring at screens
the traditional forms of bullying have
temporarily receded into the background
though that's only increased
opportunities for the cyber bullyings to
bullies to do their worst unfortunately
but once all the schools are opened
again
whenever that is hopefully within the
next decade these
anti-bullying campaigns will return to
prominence
and the thing about anti-bullying
campaigns is that they're always
as painfully ridiculous and ineffectual
as pink shirt day in canada
there has never been an anti-bullying
campaign that's managed to rise above
the pink shirt day tier
why is that i'm glad you asked the
problem with anti-bullying campaigns is
that they focus
on the wrong person now i'm quite
certain that
what i'm about to say here will be
wildly misconstrued and taken out of
context par for the course
but i'll say it anyway the real problem
with bullying today
is the way the bullying is handled by
the victim call this victim blaming if
you want that's not the label i would
use
but either way this is my point there
have always been bullies in the world
right there always will be bullies in
the world we've all been guilty of
bullying at some point
probably many points in our lives we've
also been the victims of bullying at
some point probably many points in our
lives
the bully and victim camps are the same
camp
it would be nice if we could keep the
two apart right very neatly you got the
bullies here you got the victims
here uh bad guys good guys
but we can't because they're all
together all a jumbled mess
it's like trying to divide the world
between those who tell lies
and those who are lied to it may be true
that some people obviously are more
honest than others but does anyone want
to claim that they've never told a lie
if you do make that claim well that's
just another lie to add to your list
so bullying is something that we've all
experienced on both ends
that's because we're human beings and
we're flawed
sometimes we can be mean to each other
that's especially the case when we're
kids
what this means is that there's no
reason to think that
that bullying happens more now than it
ever did or that it's worse now than it
ever was
bullying is born from our nature as
human beings and our nature as human
beings
hasn't changed in the last 10 years or
20 years or whatever
yet it does seem like kids today are
more affected
by bullying than they've ever been
they're developing
complexes and neuroses and insecurity
sometimes to a crippling extent some
children in the most extreme cases
end up killing themselves something that
was that was
simply unheard of back in the old days i
mean you didn't hear about
a 12 year old child killing themselves
because they were bullied certainly not
as not as not as common as it is today
the popular explanation for this change
is that the bullying is worse
more common more vicious and so on but i
don't think that's
there's much evidence for that and as i
said an understanding of human nature
leads one to doubt
that bullies would be any meaner now
than they've ever been
the issue it would seem is that kids
today are more vulnerable to the
bullying
less emotionally and psychologically
equipped to confront it and handle it
is it just a matter of kids being soft
or weak no that would be a gross
oversimplification the problem
is that kids today because they spend
all day around their peers in public
school
lockdowns non-withstanding and and they
carry that peer culture around with them
in their pockets on their phones
which means that even when they're not
in school still they can't escape it
because of this they've become
desperately dependent on their peers for
acceptance and approval
kids have always wanted acceptance and
approval from their friends obviously
everybody wants that
everyone's always wanted that the
difference is that through the school
system and modern technology kids today
cannot
ever get away from each other they are
always around each other in some form
always immersed in each other's business
each other's lives
this not only has the effect of
conditioning them to seek approval
constantly but it also raises the stakes
it means that
the consequences of being shamed by your
peers rejected humiliated
those consequences cannot ever be
escaped from the child's perspective
mockery at school turns into mockery
online it's everywhere
you can't just go home and it goes away
at least for a few hours doesn't work
that way
so when i say that the problem with
bullying today is the way that the
bullied
kids are more vulnerable to it that is
not to blame the victim
it's not our children's fault that this
is the world we've given to them
it's our fault but we should understand
that
the bullying is not the problem in and
of itself the bullies we will always
have with us
the problem is that we've we've thrown
our kids into an environment
where they are at the bully's mercy all
the time
everywhere and they are conditioned more
than any other generation of children in
history
to depend on the approval of their peers
which means that when that approval is
rescinded the effect can be dire even
fatal
so what's the answer
the answer is for parents to as much as
possible insulate their children from
this
suffocating stifling ubiquitous
peer culture give them a life outside of
that give them a chance to breathe
orient them so that they they look
somewhere else for approval and
affirmation
they look to you hopefully that's where
they should be looking
you know uh parents who send their kids
to public schools especially these days
experience we've gotten so used to this
we take it for granted we think it's
just this is the way it's supposed to be
but
there is oftentimes a very sudden moment
like a moment in time that parents can
tell you about
when um you know their kid is just a
normal kid
and they they love mommy and daddy and
uh and
and they want approval from their
parents and then something happens
and it's like a severing and they don't
care about their parents anymore
they don't care what their parents think
they even like
hate their parents for no apparent
reason um and
it's all about their peers
you know and this can happen happens at
different ages
it can happen at the age of of nine
years old it happens at 12 13.
now parents talk about this like it's
normal like it says the way it always
it's just how kids are it's not normal
it's normal now it doesn't have to be
we've set up our culture so it works
this way
but it shouldn't work this way
the reason why it happens is because the
kids again are immersed in that peer
culture
so much that at a certain point and it
can happen very suddenly
they just stop caring about anything or
anyone else
the goal then should be to get them to
look to you
as the parent now this is hard to do but
that has to be our goal as parents
and that means maybe not giving your 12
year old a smartphone
um carefully regulate his time online
force him to have a life a real life
homeschooling can be a big help here
give your child the sort of emotional
psychological
conditioning that he needs the sort of
living condition that he needs
in order to deal with the bullies when
they come which they will
because that's life and it's not going
to change
and that's why who's canceled again
canada that's why canada is cancelled
um and uh we took uh we took a long path
around to get back around to
canada is canceled which which i mean
really canada would have been canceled
regardless of any of this anyway
um it was it was just time for another
another one i was looking for an excuse
and i found it a little bit of an
example right now of bullying this is me
bullying canada at the moment but they
deserve it so that's it canada's
cancelled
we'll leave it there for today thanks
for watching thanks for listening have a
great day
godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadosky
the show is edited by danny d'amico our
audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is done by nika geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters
the matte wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire
2021 a new gallup poll shows a huge
spike
in lgbt identity mitt romney makes a
shocking prediction about 2024
and a joe biden hhs official supports
puberty blockers for kids
check it out on the michael knoll show